j'arrive comme ça c'est sa coupe un
petit peu c'est pas mal on se situe dans
quelle gamme de prix
[Musique]
on est aujourd'hui à londres pour
participer à un événement qui s'appelle
le bet 2019 un événement autour de
l'éducation autour des technologies
vraiment hyper cool aujourd'hui je vous
parle pas du bet
aujourd'hui je vous ramène à paris où je
vous parle audio je vous parle casca kg
je vous parle samsung et je vous parle
aussi neige voilà on prend tout ça en
balanche dans une boîte et vous avez ce
qui arrive maintenant
[Musique]
wouah neige sur paris ça caille
on n'est pas loin de la place de la
république pour aller voir samsung a kg
ha kg qui est une marque de samsung qui
fait des casques audio
alors moi je connais à calais depuis
très longtemps bien avant qu'il soit
racheté par samsung et franchement je
dois dire que j'aime plutôt la marque
l'inde a toute une nouvelle collection
j'ai vraiment hâte de voir ce que ça va
donner
donc ce que je propose c'est de
retourner se mettre au chaud parce que
là il fait froid il neige plein temps
c'est plutôt cool sur paris ça à [ __ ]
la merde de tous les contacts les
voitures mais franchement c'est cool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
ans
c'est là on est filmé en plus doux le
film excellent stress n'en parle avec
thomas thomas tu vois c'est chez samsung
à cacher bonjour bonjour comment
représente 5 tsonga kg samsung comment
samsung samsung donc et à cacher kim
ngan le produit de samsung
donc là il ya des nouveautés produit
exact on va commencer par le n 700 watts
le n500 le voici
est ce un casque à réduction de bruit
c'est le fait taper dessus comme puis
tous les deux la magie du cinéma n 7 100
m c'est ok il intègre une réduction de
bruit donc ce qui est vraiment très
pratique puisque ce casque est destiné
avant tout aux voyageurs hockey qui va
pouvoir prendre son vol
vous profitez d'une réduction de bruit
et donc profiter de sa musique sans être
perturbés par les bruits environnement
du moteur alors ce qu'on peut faire
c'est ce qu'on peut activer si ce qu'on
appelle une mode ambiante aware hockey
qui permet d'être à l'écouté des bruits
environnants dans son environnement et
donc de d'avoir l'information
parlant de la porte d'embarquement pour
son vol et ensuite profiter de la
réduction de bruit pour avoir sa musique
pendant son vol
typiquement t à l'aéroport tu dis voilà
ce moment là j'ai besoin de paix trop
fermé sur l'extérieur d'entendre ce qui
se passe j'active à un micro en fait qui
va venir être capté à son extérieur et
du rectum ans exactement et comme ceux
ci on a l'information clé tout en
écoutant sa musique qu'on reste connecté
à son environnement et une fois
confortablement installé dans son siège
au profit du confort et du son signature
à kg tout au long de son vol dont gros
coussins pour venir vraiment prendre la
forme des oreilles exactement sa mémoire
de forme
neymar de forme est effectivement un
arceau qui permet avec un revêtement
moussé également qui permet d'avoir un
confort pour dose en terme de prix on
est à peu près au
sommes à peu près à 350 euros lorsque tu
mets ton casque comme ça au final
toujours les écouteurs possesseurs
extérieur que les axes héritage studio
kg exactement
c'est une des signatures de dkk j'ai
donc et c'est de toujours être à
l'écouté de sa musique
oui donc c'est un héritage des casques
professionnels ok sur lequel justement
profil me travaillait sa musique sur sa
console mais il avait toujours ce lien
avec la musique et ne perdait pas le fil
de son travail
[Musique]
je sais tout et après ouais t'es super
gentil ça s'est désolé je vous mets au
chômage technique ce qui est cool avec
ce casque c'est la qualité du son c'est
à dire un son qui est assez pur des
médiums qui sont vraiment bien restituer
une belle précision au niveau des
médiums et en règle générale ça se
trouve au niveau des 15 kg c'est à dire
on va pas avoir un spread qui va être
trop flatteur comme avec des casques
beats par exemple trop flatteur dans la
basse et qui dénaturent vraiment la
qualité du son personnellement je n'aime
pas particulièrement ces quelques heures
je trouve que a contrario les casques à
kg et le boulot qu'ils vraiment fait au
niveau de la restitution audio par ac
âgé qu'elle fait aujourd'hui mais comme
et effet déjà avant au niveau du
moniteur de studio c'est vraiment de se
dire on garde la volonté de l'artiste en
garde la précision on apporte une belle
couleur une vraie couleur rosso une
belle précision des médiums des aigus
qui sont très précis aussi très jolie
des graves qui sont juste pas de
surenchère au niveau de la basse et ce
après coup c'est vraiment conforme
nous avons le n 60 nc qui reprend la
technologie de russian bruit du n 7
cents la différence c'est d'abord un
produit qui va être un peu plus compact
est également plus pliable donc facile à
transporter qu'on peut mais d'accord
tout sa pochette et l'envié avec soin
par tous
glock différence c'est que c'est un
supra donc ils se posent sur les
oreilles comment on va retrouver le son
signature à kg les poussins 1 à mémoire
de forme
l'arceau
en aluminium avec un pro fort pour
l'utiliser à deux longueurs
et effectivement un contrôle via
quelques boutons ici d'activation de
chargement de piste très facile des
jarres est comme ça c'est sa coupe un
petit peu c'est pas mal on se situe dans
quelle gamme de prix entre 250 à 300
euros suivant d'abord gueule suivant
l'endroit où entre quelques tu manges
[Rires]
[Musique]
pas mal ça va ça se passe bien toi tu
vois ces symptômes
oui ça change la donne j'espère que ça
tient le truc avec l'espèce de crochets
wichelen bon ça va alors on y colle sur
quel événement aujourd'hui écoute on est
sur l'événement à kg pour découvrir sous
les casques
touristes à la dose et j'ai pas encore
bon et bien que 500 alors là on est on
bascule dans un peu d'utilisateurs on
était sur des voyageurs n'ont pas
d'accès sur plutôt l'urbain l'actif au
quotidien puisqu'on retrouve toujours sa
signature à kg c'est à dire cette
ouverture toujours vers la musique les
cercles rond qui ferme qui également ça
c'est la signature et quelle jeunesse à
égal c'est la signature design aka gcc
cercle rond on les retrouve sur tous les
cas ce qui surtout les écouteurs quelle
est la particularité ici c'est un mode
lecture aux automatique d'accord ok très
simple on pose son casque sur les
oreilles la musique est active ok je
l'enlève parce que je sors du métro j'ai
quelque chose à regarder
la musique c'est un sarkozy en fin de
compte la peau de la pause effectivement
le port du casque et je leur mets sur
l'oreille la musique repas donc c'est
simple ça va bien avec usage actif qu'on
peut avoir ce casque d'accord et l'autre
point c'est le fait d'avoir une heure de
lecture pour 5 me de charges d'accord ok
donc tous les casques sont en micro usb
tout à fait ok on est sûr qu'elle paris
sans soudure publie à 160 euros 160
euros lord et celui qu'ils ont plus
large le noir le vert alain quella
l'endroit du colloque du regard
[Musique]
quel temps paris aujourd'hui
il neige plein droit bon alors au final
que penser de ces casques akg âgées à
toute première chose c'est qu'on voit un
lélio la série on va en reparler très
très prochainement parce que il ya plein
de choses à dire dessus je trouve
vraiment intéressant moi ce que j'aime
vraiment c'est la qualité audio la
restitution de l'audio et franchement
hyper propres hyper clean et ça arrive
pour ça franchement j'adore
après je suis un peu grâce à bussang ma
façon la réduction bruit parce que je la
trouve vraiment moins bonne que ce qu'on
peut retrouver chez sony notamment sur
le w h et ericsson 3 ou sur le produit
de bose parce qu'on n'a pas du tout la
même
j'essaie de me casser la gueule on n'a
pas du tout le même
la même réduction de bruit et pour avoir
conduit dans des tarifs qui sont
sensiblement similaires
ça c'est un petit peu là on a vu où où
ça va coincer par contre le gros point
fort de ce produit le canadien
c'est tombé ça tient ouf ce qui va faire
la force de ce produit c'est très
clairement la signature audio la
signature à kg qui est une qualité audio
qui est vraiment très très très bien
reproduite alors là j'ai été très
rapidement lors de la démonstration mais
j'ai vraiment hâte de les voir au studio
dans notre condition pour pouvoir
vraiment comparer c'est pas mal qu'une
entreprise comme samsung et rachetée à
cacher j'aimerais me l'a t il encore
plus de qualité au niveau des hauts
parleurs des smartphones et rien que
pour ça c'est franchement une excellente
nouvelle
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire ce que vous aimez à kg est
ce que vous trouvez que c'est une marque
intéressante et est-ce qu'au final en
achetant un casque à réduction de bruit
à 350 euros est ce que vous pourriez
aller sur la solution d'un kg
je serai bien évidemment lorsque vous
restez vu ici et ça va vous ne marquez
tout sans commentaire on en reparle puis
là je vais essayer de me frayer un
chemin dans neige parisienne c'est cool
hein je suis super content j'adore le
temps des jeux c'est magnifique
voilà mais je vous laisse profiter un
petit peu de cette jolie neige et je te
rendez vous très bientôt d'ici là soyez
sages nous faut des gros bisous ya
bientôt ciao
[Musique]